your parents you know they were pretty
they knew you were growing up around
actors and directing and a kind of a
heady lifestyle but they kept you in
line your Bar Mitzvah yeah was held at a
homeless shelter yeah I can't think of a
worse night probably in retrospect I say
that was a cool thing but but at did
your audience go to that um I I wouldn't
babe regretting Lee probably went oh
yeah you know we did have a party you
know I mean there was a you know we did
I did get a party and everything fun
party but don't you think it annoyed the
homeless people to they probably could
give this little peckerhead one of his
[ __ ] party this [ __ ] absolutely
yeah but I did I did I mean like my
parents my dad's Christian my mom's
Jewish so they were always trying to
figure out how to raise us Rio and raise
us you know with some sort of sense of
spirituality so you know the best thing
they could come to was well we think
giving back is the way to kind of bring
both religions into play to become a man
you know and I was like all right and
and then we did it I mean it seemed
pretty pretty simple made sense to me
that by the way when you're at the
homeless shelter by mister yes you have
to like serve food to the homeless while
you're yes you do
yes oh my god occupy my dream in there
you're serving food at your bar mitzva
yeah we're not just sitting there like
okay what are the other guests doing
when they were seen the same thing
yep Tony Lee helping out oh yeah wait a
second what at you Bar Mitzvah
yeah you do it's not it wasn't a Bar
Mitzvah necessary party yeah well no no
no the party was asked after okay
they were like a number of things we did
my dad I don't wear this bar mystery
story I ever heard this I didn't even
understand it let's say I get invited to
figure this out you want to be invited
to my movie let's say I was there so
would you hand me a ladle and say look
handle I think it like ship thanks to
Louie house yeah you would I think it's
[ __ ] ladle there I think I might have
left I don't know I mean tell me I
assure you there's a party afterwards
they're beautiful women in but I'm not
used to have to I'm dressed up in a suit
I can hand out to the homeless I don't
know if I can do no you're making this
this is not how it happened with your DJ
a homeless guy
the partying homeless guys left man